one Mighty Morphing Power Rangers  wristwatch Communicator toy was placed  into the Clockworks on the setting very  fine the output produced was the  following the same wristcom upon putting  it on to test Communications functions  the d-class Disappeared in a beam of  orange light that shot off towards the  western United States satellite tracked  it for 27 minutes until it reached the  Brandeis Barton campus at the American  Jewish University in Simi Valley  California where the d-class  rematerialized and impacted the roof  d-class terminated Professor Wren was  baffled by this until he looked at the  satellite photos of the place the  d-class wound up that building was  apparently used as the command center in  the original Power Rangers